the daily wire has been all over the
situation in loudoun county which has
national implications because obviously
it's going to be very important for this
virginia gubernatorial race and should
terry mcauliffe lose the gubernatorial
race in virginia basically that's the
end of joe biden's agenda because a
bunch of moderate democrats across the
country are going to look at their seats
and think if terry mcauliffe loses in
relatively blue virginia that means that
the american public are not happy with
the agenda that we are currently pushing
at that point joe biden's agenda is
basically dead until after the midterms
and probably beyond that the midterms
don't look like they are shaping up well
for him so everyone is focusing in on
loudoun county our reporter luke roziak
over in loudoun county has been doing an
unbelievable job of uncovering the
predations of the school board in
loudoun county and the democratic party
infrastructure
in places like virginia and loudoun
county with regard to school boards by
the way the kind of work that luke is
doing that's really expensive and
difficult work that can only happen
because of our daily wire members if
you're already a member thank you for
making that happen because honestly your
membership helped pay for luke but if
you're not a member you really should
join up and help our reporters do the
kind of work that luke is doing it's
making a huge difference out there head
on over to dailywear right now and grab
a membership obviously this has become a
flashpoint
because the national school board union
came out and basically
requested that the fbi and doj
investigate people who are going to
school board meetings and sounding off
on how the school boards were not doing
their job in terms of educating and
protecting their kids well
the the biggest story of the last couple
of months came out via luke a little bit
earlier this week that was the story
surrounding a father who was made the
face of the quote-unquote domestic
terror movement by the national media it
turns out that that father was royally
ticked off at one of these meetings not
because he was domestic terrorist but
because as it turns out there's fairly
good evidence and he alleges that his
daughter was raped in a public school
bathroom by a bisexual boy wearing a
skirt and that the loudoun county school
board refused to acknowledge that the
sexual assault had even taken place
which might piss off
even the best of us
and so this became a national story well
now it turns out there is even more
according to luke rosiak this morning
loudon county public schools did not
record multiple known incidents of
alleged sexual assault in schools dating
back several years despite a law that
requires statistics about school safety
incidents to be reported to the public
and which includes provisions holding
school superintendents personally liable
for violations a daily wire review of
public records found after the daily
wire raised the discrepancy with the
virginia department of education the
vdoe spokesman charles pyle said vdoe is
reviewing the discipline crime and
violence data submissions of loudoun
county public schools and is in
communication with lcps to determine
whether the division's reporting is
accurate and whether the division is in
compliance with state and federal law
the same law could have implications for
loudoun county superintendent or
principal in the wake of a may 28
alleged sexual assault in a bathroom an
incident first reported by the daily
wear on monday on june 22nd
superintendent scott ziegler told the
public
to my knowledge we don't have any record
of assaults occurring in our bathrooms
virginia law requires that reports shall
be made to the division superintendent
and to the principal or his designee on
all incidents involving sexual assault
the daily wire asked lcps questions last
week including quote has stone bridge
ever reported the may alleged sexual
assault in any statistics or made anyone
aware of it lcps hid behind state law
with director of communications joan
sogwein replying quote any information
related to student information is
confidential under state and federal
laws regarding student privacy however
state law actually requires statistics
on assault and other incidents in
schools to be reported to the public in
the form of annually updated statistics
available on a public database called
safe schools information resource
administered by the virginia department
of education in other words the school
board and the school does not have to
report to the public the name of the
people involved the juveniles involved
but they do have to report the numbers
lcps reported to the state that
stonebridge had zero sexual assaults for
the 2020 to 2021 school year which
includes may 28 2021.
virginia law says the super the division
superintendent shall annually report all
such incidents to the doe for the
purpose of recording the frequency of
such incidents on forms that shall be
provided to the department and shall
make such information available to the
public
the issue with missing sex assault
statistics in loudon is not limited to
the latest case raising the prospect and
untold numbers of sexual assaults and
other infractions have gone unreported
in october 2018 in a case that was
widely reported by the media at the time
three football players at tesco herrera
tuscarera high were arrested and charged
with sexual assault a source told local
media it's believed a younger player was
held down by teammates who inserted
victims who inserted objects into the
victim in a locker room a spokesperson
for lcps said at the time the case will
be subject to disciplinary action the
annual report for tuscarera that you
reported zero instances of sexual
offenses against students
lcps provided no response at all to the
daily wires questions about the reason
for the zero figures despite having two
days to do so
while the suspect in the may 28 alleged
assault was not arrested until july 8
following the conclusion of an
investigation police officers were
present at the school that day law
enforcement was notified and a police
report was filed though it was not clear
who filed the report
pyle the state spokesman told
said that the sssr's mandatory reporting
is not contingent on the filing of
charges by law enforcement or subsequent
convictions in other words if this was
reported to the cops that just means
that it has to be reported in the stats
but it wasn't reported in the stats
additionally the safety stats for that
school year were not due to the state
until july 16th and in the case of
tuscarera the school year did not end
until months after the incident and
arrest yet the district still reported
zero and has for every single year since
on wednesday lcps put out a statement we
did not send it to the daily wire it
said quote loudon county sheriff's
office was contacted within minutes of
receiving the initial report on may 28th
once a matter has been reported to law
enforcement lcps does not begin its
investigation until law enforcement
advises lcps it has completed the
criminal investigation furthermore we
can't discipline any student without
following title ix grievance processes
but an email from stonebridge principal
tim flynn which was sent to the entire
community at 448 the day of the alleged
rape told students and parents that
quote there was an incident in the main
office area today that required the
loudoun county sheriff's office to
dispatch deputies to stone bridge this
corresponds to the story offered by
scott smith the victim's father who said
the police arrived because the school
called them on him for making a scene
about his impression was not treating
the incident seriously
so this is a disaster area for loudoun
county if it turns out that the loudoun
county schools have not been reporting
these stats on sexual assault to the
public just another indicator that when
you have institutions that are very
powerful they have every incentive to
cover up
all of the bad things happening within
those institutions this is true across
institutions
people develop institutional loyalty
when they work for those institutions
and they don't want to report the bad
stuff happening inside the institutions
and that's how you end up with children
being put in
danger now for the left they don't care
apparently if those children are put in
danger by the public schools and there
are a wide variety of cases in which
teachers have
have made prey out of their students in
public schools across the country those
statistics are in fact somewhat
available
it's a national story when it's the
catholic church it's not a national
story when it turns out that it's the
public school system obviously even
though there are many many more members
of the public school system in the
united states than there are members of
the catholic church who are subject to
predation
okay there's certainly an ideological
component here
and meanwhile the family of that girl
who's allegedly raped in her school
bathroom is now pursuing civil action
against the loudoun county public
schools under title nine so there will
in fact be a lawsuit
the parents of the young girl stated
quote subsequent to the sexual assault
on our daughter loudoun county public
schools formalized the policy regarding
restroom use that was easily exploitable
by a potential sexual assailant because
of poor planning and misguided policies
loudoun schools failed to institute even
minimal safeguards to protect students
from sexual assault
the lawyer for the family says the
conduct of loudoun county schools and
the loudoun school board directly
resulted in the brutal rape of smith's
daughter at stonebridge high it only
takes an instant to see how loud and
county schools have adversely affected
this family and have harmed their
daughter
so all of this has resulted in some
pretty bad
news for terry mcauliffe who's running
for governor of virginia and who is
completely in hawk to the teachers
unions in the state of virginia he was
asked yesterday about whether parents
should be in charge of education and
this of course remains a major issue
right across the country parents would
like to be in charge of their children's
education public schools are delegated
your kids to educate them in the ways
that you see fit they're not delegated
to the power to educate them solely as
they see fit
because frankly they are not
qualified to do so nor empowered to do
so that is not the purpose of local
public schools
and the federalization of the process
has made this worse it's created a
massive disconnect between the
bureaucrats who are supposed to educate
your children and you this is why
increasingly parents are taking their
kids out of the public schools putting
them in private schools homeschooling
them
trying to find charter schools doing
anything they can to renew to remove the
monopoly on indoctrination now provided
by liberal teachers unions
and the and the state-run
schooling system and so terry mcauliffe
was asked about all of this because he
had said in open debate with glenn
youngkin in virginia that parents
essentially have no interest in the
education of their kids it's really the
state's job to educate the kids here is
terry mcauliffe erupting when asked
about it
who do you think should be in control of
education if not virginia parents
vaccinated yeah that's the question i
want to know who do you think should be
in control of education if not virginia
parents the governor
dangerous here closed last year i'll
build
that's education fox news has me leading
the uncle destroy virginia's education
system what a joke terry mcauliffe is
what a joke so he's asked whether
parents should be in control of
education he starts lecturing the guy
about a mass they're standing outside
he's literally walking to his car if you
can't see the clip he's literally
walking to his car and just yelling at
this reporter
saying that he should be wearing a mask
and then he says i'll take care of
education glen youngkin will destroy it
yeah sure
sure
so terry mccoll is in real trouble in
this race okay this should not be a
close race
the the virginia
political map has been turning blue for
quite a while right now the results in
virginia in the 2020 election were
heavily in favor of course of hillary in
favor of joe biden joe biden won the
state by 10 points in 2020. right now
youngkin is who's a relative no name is
running neck and neck with terry
mcauliffe a former virginia governor
it's the fact that this is even close is
a referendum on how bad people think
democratic governance is even in
democratic states
this has relegated terry mcauliffe to
basically trying to treat glenn youngkin
as though he is donald trump and also
greg abbott which of course is not true
here is terry mcauliffe trying to say
that glenn young is going to ban
abortion in the state of virginia which
of course is not going to happen i mean
unfortunately from my point of view but
that's not what's going to happen in the
state of virginia
i protected women's rights he is going
to ban abortions we got him on tape
saying that wants to ban abortions in
virginia and i'll tell you andrew that's
a real issue for everyone today for 50
years we thought the supreme court would
protect everybody with roe v wade trump
supreme court if glenn younkin is
elected governor of virginia abortions
will cease and i gotta tell you it's
dangerous for women dangerous for
doctors and you can't bring businesses
on recruited amazon to virginia they're
not coming to a state that discriminates
he's having a really tough time
mcauliffe putting a target on yonkins
back because mcauliffe is the issue here
not trump and not junkin and when it
comes to education americans have very
simple questions to ask like why are you
guys doing an unbelievably crappy job
brand new report out says the nation's
13 year olds are less proficient in math
and reading than they were almost a
decade ago that is not because of the
covet pandemic that was data collected
before the start of the pandemic and
released on thursday according to the
national assessment of education
progress this political reporting this
is the first time these scores have
dropped in either subject in the 50
50 year history of the test
the students who struggle the most with
the exam have fallen further behind a
worrisome result that suggests learning
loss exacerbated by the pandemic could
be catastrophic
math scores fell furthest among students
whose performance ranked in the 10th and
25th percentiles meaning test takers
with the lowest math scores in 2020 did
worse than students who struggled the
most when the test was last administered
in 2012. the data also shows the
achievement gap between white and black
test takers widened
nationally math scores for 13 year olds
fell on average by five points reading
scores declined on average three points
none of these results are impressive
said the commissioner of the national
center for education statistics they're
all concerning the math results were
particularly daunting
so basically your schools are failing to
educate kids particularly the kids who
are at the lowest ends of the spectrum
and meanwhile they're indoctrinating
them in all the worst values not
protecting them and you wonder why we
have a schools crisis right now you
wonder why so many parents are
interested in pulling their kids out of
school and you wonder why many people
are looking at scans at democratic
administrations who seem solely
concerned with pleasing teachers unions
you you wonder how many americans are
upset with maybe the fbi and the doj
doing the bidding of the very people who
are failing to educate their kids and
then claiming complete plenary authority
over those children
none of this is good news for democrats
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe